I think things have got to come up to
date in evolutionary biology and
recognize that essentially Darwin would
never have been a neo-darwinian
[Music]
Dennis Noble welcome to how the light
gets in I am very happy to be here and
delighted to have this discussion with
you
in one form or another as you've claimed
the idea of genetic determinism this
idea that our behavior is controlled can
be predicted by the inner workings of
our biological makeup goes back a very
long time you point out that you can
find it in Descartes yes in the 17th
century Japan that's right yes why do
you think this idea has sort of such a
lasting appeal
I think it has been a big mistake
or maybe philosophical for a moment
of dualism
see Descartes was a dualist
he dealt with the problem of the
mechanics of an organism by saying there
must be a spiritual entity that
interacts with the mechanics this was
Cartesian dualism
and in a sense the dualism of the
replicator being in communication with
and conducting the vehicle is a
resurrection of the same kind of problem
we don't need dualism
the agency of organisms comes from
within us it doesn't come from some
ghostly outside
I don't even know what that would mean
if I'd try to give it meaning so I think
it's fairly easy to see where it comes
from because obviously it has to have
some degree of non-determinate function
otherwise it would be determinate so
what we're talking about is can there be
Innovation can it be creativity that's
the key question now the darwinian
rather than Neo darwinian answer to that
is
well there is chance there is
stochasticity but it's not used it is
just simply determining how many
breakages how many changes occur
naturally in the genome and then natural
selection comes along and automatically
works out which are successful and which
are not and I accept that that obviously
is that is the way things happen that's
fine
now I just reversed that
by saying that in addition to that
process organisms can actually go and
use the chance and they're doing that
all the time see the way our immune
systems work shows that what happens
when a new virus or new bacterium or new
anything else arrives is first the
immune system I'm going to use some
anthropological way of saying it but we
all know this has to do with molecular
processes
what it does is to try to find out
whether it's got
a sequence that already can latch onto
that virus or that bacterium in which
case it just multiplies those cells so
he's got the feedback there already if
it already exists if it doesn't it does
something quite fascinating it goes to
the nucleus and says please stop the
error correction
and allow the brakes to occur and then
we will select out of those the very few
that can grab hold of this new virus
that's how the immune system works now
what I'm saying is that's General
it happens in bacteria when they resist
antibiotics it happens in cancers where
they resist radiotherapy and
chemotherapy what do they do they also
hypermutate they use chance to get
novelty and I think that's what
organisms are doing all the time the
answer therefore I think to the question
are we creative first of all it's
obvious we are how do you get a
Beethoven how do you get an Einstein if
we're not but the question is can
physiologists explain that and I think
they can if you can bring that
stochastic process under some kind of
control you then do the selecting then
you can end up with creativity
to go back to your claim that this sort
of gene-centric or determined Gene
deterministics view is founded on a kind
of dualistic picture of the human as
divided between the body and something
else do you find that animates even
contemporary versions of this idea of
the gene Centric
um deterministic Yes actually because I
I I don't want to I don't want to
diminish the reputation of Richard
Dawkins I've acknowledged that many
times his book is clearly the best
exposition of neodywinism we've got
popular Exposition it naturally sells in
millions of copies but I don't think the
great majority of research biologists
are any longer following that path in
the way in which he laid it out so I'm
sorry to say I think the ground has
shifted quite a long way you see in in
the debate we've just hadn't he
preferred to call it a conversation I'm
happy with calling it a conversation but
in what we've just done
it seems to me that what that showed was
that I don't think people like Richard
yet know that that things really have
moved on very rapidly did we know a few
years ago that there could be tiny
particles that can carry rnas and dnas
to the germline no we didn't
that's within the last 20 years
so there is a shift here it's in
principle of enormous proportions and
whether people are waking up to that in
the public media I rather doubt but they
really should because has big big
implications
what do you see as the main fault of
this old picture the the gene Centric
surface Gene Richard Dawkins Neo
darwinian yes picture of of ourselves
what's the main kind of objection that
you have to that well the main one I've
got is actually a health and wealth
a Health and Welfare problem
we've spent literally billions now in
the world
sequencing genomes now I'm not
denying the importance of the genome
sequencing it has clearly given us the
possibility of establishing trees of
life and so on as we compare the genomes
of different species that is brilliant
that's good fundamental science
but I'm a physiologist I teach medical
students
from the point of view of what was
promised 20 odd years ago in relation to
cures for cancer cures for diabetes
cures for Alzheimer cures you name it
there was going to be these cures coming
from the sky almost as we got to know
which genes caused which what have we
found
the association levels are quite tiny
now physiologists like me seeing that
data says but we know why
I've been an experiment that I described
in the debate is very obviously
illustrating that we found a major
protein that contributes to the rhythm
of the heart how frequently it beats we
know it contributes about 80 percent of
the current that generates that rhythmic
frequency knock it out with a Blocker of
that protein or knock the gene out what
do you find a very modest change in
frequency
now that doesn't mean that it didn't
contribute 80 percent of the
functionality we know it did we measured
it what it means is that another
mechanism kicks in and we know what that
was so we've been able to show that from
a physiological point of view The
Association scores don't really tell us
very much you can even have an
association of zero
for a gene that is actually functional
now that's striking but what that means
is just reading your genome you won't
know that you won't even see that so I
think the big issue for me is when are
we going to wake up to the fact that
we've spent 20 years now sequencing as
many genomes as we can the output as
promised simply hasn't appeared if we
appreciate why that happened why that
failure happened we can then shift to a
better way of doing it and we knew what
that was before genome sequencing what
we did was to look at the high-level
organization of the system the living
system
locate what is going wrong there and
then work down to find what you might do
at lower levels with a drug
or any other kind of treatment for that
matter to put it right and that works
much better than trying to go the other
way because going the other way
oh the the space for possible molecules
and possible effects and even more
possible combinations of effects because
those complex diseases are going to
require combinations of uh of of of
treatment
there are too many you can't do clinical
trials on all of those possibilities
it's just far too expensive so I think
we just take need to take a different
approach to research medical research to
try to benefit from the human genome
sequencing in a way that's different
from what they originally promised the
new medications haven't fallen out of
the sky we now need to take up the
pieces and work out why that was the
case I think I've already explained that
and then what do we do about it and how
do we do a better way of getting Health
Care sorted out because it's urgent to
do so we've got aging populations
they're going to swamp our health
services this is really urgent so the
previous picture in your mind suffered
from this almost reductionist impulse
that everything was reduced to the level
of the Gene and once we found what genes
were for
each disease we could then treat it but
as you say there isn't actually there is
things there isn't a program there I'm
afraid you see I I'm a programmer I know
how to write if then else and if so then
that and so on you know you can do that
industry it's what programming does
there is no such program in the genome
you look there and try and find it you
won't find it what you've got is a
series of switches
because it is true that each sequence
that can be used to make an RNA a
protein has a place where it can be
switched on or off sure but that's the
switch
it's not the if then Logic the logic is
not there
you've said that this approach is sort
of neo-darwinian and in a way you were
hinting that it goes against the kind of
fundamental tenets of Charles Darwin
himself absolutely so how do you see the
the difference between those two what
was Charles Darwin's View and how did it
get distorted by Neo Darwin yes I think
what Neo Darwinism did was to take his
initial the discovery for which is
initially rightly respected enormously
which is natural selection which is the
key element in the Origin of Species and
in the joint papers he did with Wallace
at the previous year 1858.
so rightly Darwin is praised for that
but he was a much more nuanced thinker
about Evolution he went on worrying
about this all the way through his life
first in the Origin of Species itself he
already includes use and disuse as a
mechanism of evolution
even the great modern synthesis
Ernst Mayer in his big book on
biological thought about 30 40 years ago
at the time of the Centenary of the
original species he wrote you know in
Darwin I can see 12 places where he
acknowledges lamarkian mechanisms so it
wasn't absent in 1859 but by 1868 he
formulated a theory
which he then went on for the next 10
years of his life to try to prove he was
that devoted to it now his theory was
very simple it was that the use and
disuse in the body can get communicated
to the germline how can it do that if
there aren't particles that do that he
couldn't see them so he admitted at that
time you find that in his 1868 book he
says this is a this is a guess this is a
hypothesis
we've now found them and they are the
tiny particles the cells all over the
body are pouring out all the time I mean
when Richard told me during the debate
you know he would need all of this
information to be tried well it is
transmitted
so I I I think things have got to come
up to date in evolutionary biology and
recognize that essentially Darwin would
never have been a neo-darwinian
he would not have accepted the Weissman
barrier otherwise he wouldn't have
developed his theory of generals to
explain how information could go from
the Sameer to the germline he would have
never accepted the idea that natural
selection was the only mechanism and he
says that specifically so I think if
he'd lived to hear weissmann giving his
famous lecture in 1883 on the isolation
of a germline he died in 1882 so he
couldn't but if he'd lived to it I think
he would have said no you're wrong
what's the alternative picture to this
sort of genetic determinism
you've used a metaphor in the past
of thinking of genes not as a
as a code as you said but as a kind of
musical score yes and as a score that
can be interpreted in various different
ways can you tell us a little bit more
about the way you think about this yes
well I am as it happens a musician I
actually give a big concert tomorrow in
Oxford in the sheldonian theater
but no I've obviously taken from my
musical side of my life this metaphor
for a very good reason if you look at a
score
of Bach Beethoven Mozart whatever you
want to take and you look at different
orchestras and different soloists
interpreting those scores
what stands out a mile to a musician is
the differences
of course you can recognize the same
notes there but the interpretation is so
different that one can one has always to
say this is this style of playing
Beethoven is that style of being
Beethoven the same thing can be said
about Bach and I think the answer is
that the analogy is that with the same
notes you can play totally different
music and the same is true for genes
with the same genes you can play very
different behavior for example if I'm
selfish I have my selfish characteristic
at a time when I have the genes that
Dennis Noble has when I am altruistic
and very kind to people I have exactly
the same genes my genes haven't changed
between being selfish one day and being
altruistic the next day I naturally use
the same genes so genes can't be
responsible for myself business I'm
responsible for myself so what is yeah
what is the agency here where do we
locate it who's doing the interpreting
of the musical score here the organism
is the source of the interpretation now
the big question there is how do you
explain that without
recreating a duality how do you get to
that without having to make Descartes
mistake decals mistake was to suppose
there's a kind of other entity
non-material a soul a spirit whatever
you want to call it that interacts with
the mechanics as it were because he
actually thought that other animals
apart from humans were indeed mechanisms
so now interestingly most evolutionary
biologists who are the near darwinian
persuasion tend to say well humans are
also now that's difficult because we
seem to feel that we're not but put that
to one side the big question is how can
you get creativity without having to
have something up there that injects it
into you you know that lovely painting
of the fingers pointing you see and Adam
gets as it were activated by the Finger
of God we don't need that I'm not saying
whether people who believe that are
right or wrong and leave that to them
but what I do think is you don't need
that because the organism has that
ability already the reason is simply
because it could use the chance events
that occur in his molecular mechanisms
there's where the creativity comes from
then the question is what what emerges
from that do you want to keep and what
do you want to reject
it's very simple it sounds like what
you're saying is allowing for a kind of
freedom to enter into the picture of how
we think of our biology genetic
determinism makes it sound like we are a
Cartesian machine exactly we have a
Clockwork exactly but my question is
does there is there now a room for
determinism to come from Another Side
namely the environment acting upon us
yes but now let's have a look at that
because you see that stochastic as well
I I agree with you yes you could say
that the environment is itself
determining what we do now I think
that's partly true clearly I've become
the kind of person I've become through
my history so in that sense it must be
the case that the environment is a big
influence just as genes are you see I
don't deny that genes are influential
which isn't to say they're not causal in
the way that we can be as agents they're
not causing my selfishness they're not
causing other forms of my behavior now
the way I think to think about this
is that once you can harness charms use
it
you have the possibility of creating
novelty and that's what we're doing
isn't that what we call creativity
you see
before a Beethoven emerges we couldn't
have predicted I don't think musicians
before baton would have predicted what
he did he turned the apricot around and
came in with blah blah and all the rest
of it you know and turn music upside
down
and Einstein did the same with with
physics fundamental physics
I think what those people were doing was
to find the chance processes within
themselves
seeing it and then saying oh I want to
go that way that's going to shock the
world
and they go for it now sometimes they're
wrong
that's fine too that's how Science music
poetry and so on experiments and finds
its way forward if we didn't have people
who were wrong we wouldn't be where we
are so we have to encourage that
but the process I think is within
ourselves and it's based on the fact
that we are not determinate like
computers with silicon chips that are
rigid
I sometimes think of it like this
if I met a robot that looked very much
like a beautiful girl and everything
went fine together with her and me
but then I have discovered there was a
big problem
I couldn't work out why she doesn't seem
to know by where she's going what's her
purpose
this is really just being programmed by
Google to be the best person to satisfy
all my wishes but if that is all that it
does the robot
gets boring after about six months you
see
and then I asked the question but how
does the robot see it could we imagine
how the robot would see it and I think
what the robot would say would be
roughly this
oh dear
I'm made of silicon chips my molecules
yes they vibrate a bit but they don't
move around
he's made of water
what happens in water the molecules are
moving around all the time is Brownian
motion which we've known about ever
since about 1830
so
she's frustrated I wrote a story like
this that's why I can repeat it here
because it fascinates me because this
will come AI will get to the point where
we will be able to bring to to create
simulations of us well Abba have just
done that
in their magnificent performance 40 odd
years later you know so we will get to
the stage where we can recreate this
kind of almost human activity how would
we know there's a difference and I think
it would be Illustrated quite well with
the story I'm telling you which is that
the poor girl in the story would be
saying look this is terrible I know I
cannot harness chance in the way he does
see what the reason I can produce all
kinds of variations is that my Creator
built a random number generator inside
me so that I don't always do the same
thing but that isn't the same as him
because he's got a purpose that's the
difference
speaking about the future and sort of
Ai and post-human future perhaps what do
you make of
things like crispr and
human enhancement through manipulating
of our genetic material are those sort
of efforts misguided given your views
about
the role of genes in shaping our
Behavior how do you yes first of all
Christopher is very interesting indeed
because I think it illustrates the point
that there is natural ways in which
organisms can change their genomes what
does crispr do it does precisely that
and the bacteria from which there was
taken do it all the time so that's the
first point it actually illustrates part
of what I'm saying we organisms are
capable of changing our genomes
but when you come to the question could
we use it to
as it were delivered the promises of the
Human Genome Project even though they've
not yet produced it because we can say
okay if you could correct this Gene
would we have the future reassured and
we can then avoid all of these diseases
I very much doubt it and I think it's
very dangerous
because we do not know the function of
all genes
most genes in any way contribute to many
functions
so when you manipulate this one because
you know it produces this disease
what else are you doing
and if we don't know that before we use
crispr how do we know that modifying the
germline because that's what it amounts
to isn't going to produce problems in
the future
so that's why I say that I think it's
dangerous we need first to know more
about the functions of genes in general
in cooperation with each other because
they tend to work in cooperation with
each other rather than as isolated
elements in the system in that case we
need to know that before we interfere
with that system it's like a watchmaker
suddenly saying well I'm going to fix
this watch by bashing this Cog and
changing it this way without
understanding the Finesse of what has
been created
what do you think the biggest question
in molecular biology is this day is that
people aren't paying enough attention to
and should be
I think we have to get back I'm sorry to
say this because I am a physiologist we
need to get back
to a physiological interpretation now I
wrote an article just two years ago
together with a colleague and I called
it could physiology rescue genomics
I think we can
we can identify where there is causality
even when it's not shown by the
Association levels
now I've explained that in the case of
the heart I can do the modeling and I
can demonstrate it and we did the
experiments that are the basis of the
model I think that could be done much
much more and the database to do it is
already there because we have hundreds
of physiological models now on a site
which is called the salamel it's a
technical term website so we have many
of the causal models in place to
simulate what the biology is showing we
could easily
well I say easily it takes good
mathematicians and programmers to do it
but we could work out why this Gene
Association is so low and then ask the
question what would be a better way of
intervening in this system this control
system so I think the physiology could
come to the rescue of evolutionary
biology so a more holistic approach to
the organism rather than a reductionist
one I'm afraid we have to because
reductionism has failed yes
Dennis Noble thank you very much my
pleasure
[Music]
my ideas for IAI TV